microstrategy yesterday released
earnings
and they beat they just beat on
everything they're they're killing the
game
absolutely destroying the game and
michael saylor as you can see here is
the ultimate bitcoin bull he's got laser
eyes he's going to the moon he went on
cnbc this morning
and he literally was talking about
bitcoin as digital real estate he even
said you could take it to the grave with
you
i mean he is a believer and what's
fascinating is that they now have over
105
000 bitcoin over 105
000 bitcoin are on the microstrategy
balance sheet and so an exact quote was
we continue to be pleased
by the results of the implementation of
our digital asset strategy
our latest capital raise allowed us to
expand our digital holdings
which now exceed 105 000 bitcoins going
forward
we intend to continue to deploy
additional capital
into our digital asset strategy michael
saylor
bought the dip and michael sailor's not
going to stop i mean
how many bitcoin do we think that he's
going to end up acquiring before it's
all over
he's at 105 000 how many could he get he
ain't getting 21 million because he
ain't taking mine
[Laughter]
michael i love you you ain't getting
mine either john you ain't getting mine
i thought that was known all right so
he's got a 105 uh
thousand now if we look at the bitcoin
treasury as a percentage of market cap
we've got a
a chart here uh that's pretty
interesting in terms of
showing the initial purchase back in
august of 2020
you can see that uh the bitcoin treasury
at one point
was a hundred percent of the market cap
it now is oscillating big sat word there
you guys see that one you guys probably
couldn't spell that word
oscillating around 60 to 70 percent i
the fact that you didn't try to spell it
means neither one of you know i was
gonna make a joke about you but
go ahead what was the joke no go ahead
you can get a shot at me it was just
going to be a small
small joke about how you learned that
word last night but well i've known that
word for a while
i didn't do well on the s.a.t i'm more
of a a-c-t guy right john yeah
yeah john and i are a ct so he says
[Laughter]
that's the one where like if you don't
really do well in sat you're like you
take it and then you're like oh but look
at what i did on this one yeah exactly
yeah i think john and i got like 33s on
the act we were killing the game i did
all right i probably got 34 then yeah
it the lower the score the better no
[Laughter]
all right so with microstrategy
basically they're oscillating sat word
between 60 70 percent of the market cap
and then if you go and you actually look
at uh the micro strategy versus bitcoin
versus nasdaq
you can see it gets very interesting
when you start to actually compare
microstrategy has been outperforming
bitcoin and obviously the nasdaq bitcoin
has drastically outperformed nasdaq
uh bitcoin's over 200 since august of
2020
when uh microstrategy first bought
bitcoin but microstrategy stock
is up almost 400 percent obviously they
have their
uh business intelligence software side
of the business uh which is just as
uh kind of value accretive as their
actual bitcoin purchases
and so you can see when uh microstrategy
is outperforming bitcoin like that and
the nasdaq is so drastically
underperforming uh the price of bitcoin
it leads you to ask
should every company just buy bitcoin
should they all put it on their balance
sheet and so
there's a website called
bitcointreasuries.net
uh which at nvk on twitter has put
together
and we just pulled the top uh the top
companies these are the top publicly
traded companies
ranked by ownership of bitcoin and what
you can see
is a macro strategy which is a
subsidiary of
micro strategy real big uh naming
convention there
macro strategy llc which is
microstrategy uh
currently has a six billion dollar
market cap it was about a billion last
uh july and august
so at 6 billion 66
bitcoin in terms of uh holdings there
and they currently have 100 over 105 000
bitcoin
which is about half of one percent of
this
21 million supply so you look on the far
right of this chart you can see they own
about
0.5 of all 21 million bitcoin
which when you think about the fact that
they have 105 000 bitcoin that sounds
like a massive number it's only 0.5
percent of the total outstanding 21
million the cost basis
for that bitcoin is around 2.7
billion dollars and today's value is
over 4 billion so they're up 1.5 x
on that if you go down and you look at
tesla or you look at
square you can start to see that tesla
and square both
uh have spent a billion and a half for
tesla
square spent 220 million and both of
them are up
1.13 and 1.4 x but their
ownership of the 21 million outstanding
bitcoin is much much lower 0.2 and then
0.03
or 0.04 and so when you look at those
three those are the three kind of
non-bitcoin uh businesses that hold it
on their balance sheet they're not
involved in the crypto bitcoin business
square has cash app which has uh some
bitcoin exposure but for the most part
they're not in the actual industry
the other companies on this list they
are in the industry
and so again if we go back to the chart
of
microstrategy versus bitcoin versus
nasdaq it begs the question joe and john
should every company in the public
markets put some bitcoin on their
balance sheet like is that at this point
a no-brainer strategy if they're smart
[Music]
only if they're small i mean it's worked
for for microstrategy obviously i think
it depends
uh but yeah look i don't think there's
any reason why you can't hold one to two
percent of the cash on your balance
sheet in bitcoin
and why one to two percent obviously
microstrategy's chosen to go
90 percent 67 is much higher than i
think the normal person would be
obviously tesla
is mid single digits of their cash on
hand and then
uh i think that square was somewhere in
the like one to three percent or
something i think it offers that uh
asymmetric upside right without that
kind of with limited downside protection
so if you only do two percent
at worse you lose two percent it's not
going to zero right so
uh you still protect yourself on the
downside but you have that asymmetric
upside that that microstrategy has
obviously captured
uh over the last year it's a company's
doing cocktail insurance
[Laughter]
well the there's definitely a
conversation component to it right when
tesla
bought bitcoin and put it on the balance
sheet it was very obvious that
uh the mainstream media started to ask
cfos and ceos when they would
uh be interviewed are you thinking about
doing this so it definitely changed the
conversation
but from a pure financial uh performance
standpoint
yes bitcoin is volatile compared to just
sitting with cash
but the cash is guaranteed to lose value
right if you've sat with cash on your
balance sheet
since the middle of last year kind of 12
months ago to today
you actually have less purchasing power
than not bitcoin during the same time
frame has
expanded the purchasing power that you
have at by three to four x depending on
when you would have bought the bitcoin
et cetera and so
over long periods of time we heard uh
safadeen from yesterday
uh say that over any four year period in
bitcoin's history if you bought bitcoin
and held it for four years
you have more purchasing power four
years later than you did when you first
bought it well one thing that's
interesting too is and i'm not sure how
we would uh
quantify this but there's got to be some
increase in demand of the actual equity
of his company also right because
because of the institutional investors
that want exposure to bitcoin but could
not buy bitcoin historically
right so say uh i work at a big
institution we're not allowed to
physically go and buy the bitcoin
ourselves because of rules and
regulations whether it's internal
regulatory and now they go and buy
microstrategy stock to essentially get
exposure to that
it basically becomes either a tracking
stock in to some degree
right or it becomes uh like a a proxy
for an etf there is no etf
now i would argue that if people want
just pure bitcoin exposure they could
just go buy gbtc
right which is a publicly traded uh
vehicle that gives you kind of indirect
exposure to bitcoin
um but at the same time then you're
making the decision to actually buy
bitcoin yeah right like that is a
allocation decision when you're buying
the equity of a business
you could probably pass it off
internally or buying a business
intelligence uh
exactly right and then they just happen
to have this massive you know
multi-billion dollar position in bitcoin
on the balance sheet as well
it's very smart uh because also the
business intelligence unit has
beat estimates in q2 i think on both
revenue and the bottom line which is
showing you that there's a actual
business and stuff now you can argue is
you know how good is it
how fast will it grow all that but it's
bitcoin plus business intelligence
ends up actually being a a huge uh
benefit here
can we talk about how much of a gangster
michael saylor is
i was i was looking before the show and
i his stock during the dot com was at 3
100
per share and you said it dropped to one
dollar per share i think it went to
like less than a dollar that's insane
yeah 20 years later now it's i mean
it went back to kind of in the mid 100
to 200 range for a while it seemed
and now it's up into the 600s michael
saylor is one of the longest
running ceos of a publicly traded
company yeah he's been running this
company for 20 years
right in the public markets and he's
navigated multiple
uh technology advancements uh multiple
kind of
eras so the dot-com bubble the global
financial crisis
the adoption of mobile now crypto and
bitcoin etc
like he continues to uh
survive and thrive and i think that part
of
what uh is fascinating about him was
until august of 2020
he was not into bitcoin like this is not
somebody who
saw it in 2014 and was like oh i love
this then bought a bunch personally and
then like ended up making a bunch of
money
uh in uh kind of the value of their
bitcoin position and then did it with
their business
he did not kind of buy into
bitcoin until august of 2020 and one of
his best friends eric
uh was in the bitcoin it was like trying
to convince him for a while right and
eventually got him to kind of see the
light of day he ended up doing a whole
bunch of stuff around education from
reading books listening to podcasts et
cetera
it was like bam i got to do this and
then what's publicly known
is not only did he take 85 of his
balance sheet which was a high
conviction
bet yeah and convert it to bitcoin to
start
he also personally bought hundreds of
millions of dollars bitcoin as well yeah
and then on top of that he said okay i'm
not just gonna buy a bunch and stop
there
then he started to actually take on debt
whether it was you know unsecured
secured converts
you know all these different kind of
interest rates et cetera and use that to
get
capital to buy more of it so this is
somebody who understands like pressing
your winners is usually a pretty good
investment strategy
and has done a very unique
strategy to kind of position themselves
i don't understand why every other
public company doesn't go do this this
is like the most
no-brainer thing in the world if you're
a publicly traded business
well one of the things that's even more
impressive about that right is that he
missed the boat on kind of some of the
early returns that i think some people
some people owned a bitcoin and sold it
right they thought it was already kind
of
uh they capitalized and took some of the
profit and stuff like that he missed all
of that and instead of saying hey maybe
i missed the boat maybe this is kind of
too late in the trade or whatever he
just doubled down
super aggressively right he put personal
capital uh the business
he borrowed debt all this kind of stuff
and to sit there and watch your stock go
from 3 100
to a single dollar in the span of two
years and then to stay for 20 more years
and have the conviction and the courage
to do this
is incredible right and i speak i think
it speaks to uh to him as a leader
obviously
but one day we'll have to go through
i've heard some crazy stories about one
time i forget where i heard
it but he had a story about the uh the
website domains that he purchased
and kind of some of the negotiating
stories about it we'll have to dig up
the details and go through it one day it
was insane
he sold voice.com to a crypto business
for like 30 million bucks savage
exactly and if i remember correctly it
was some story about like how he
negotiated all the way up yeah they
started out with like an offer of like
100k
yeah yeah it was something like that and
he was just like no no no
no no and then they just had like
unlimited money essentially so they just
paid him some ridiculous fees you know
who else is going to have unlimited
money
him well michael saylor and probably
sofi at some point yeah sofi.com
uh no but michael saylor stands to have
one of the most valuable companies
in the stock market if the bitcoin
perspective plays out right so it is a
high conviction
in many people's eyes high risk type
strategy
i think if you ask myself or michael or
other people they would argue that this
isn't so high risk
but if it works his 4 billion
balance sheet could expand to be 40 50
60 billion
and all of a sudden if he's got a 40 50
60 billion dollar balance sheet
i mean what does the company trade
company could trade at you know hundreds
of billions of dollars in market cap
like like is is there a world where
before the end of the decade michael
saylor has a trillion dollar business
micro strategy
well it depends on the price is that six
billion right now right if bitcoin
let's just use other people's uh example
of
bitcoin ends up hitting a million
dollars after the next having right so
within this decade
if that was to happen that would mean
that michael saylor has what on his
balance sheet 105 000
uh times a million what is that number
john
i'm not a mathematician i don't do
public math and if you ask me all the
zeros and and uh the commas and stuff
very very confusing
i love that quote don't do public math
no public math going on here that's why
john's got a calculator
it's so big you got a little bit oh you
know you know that that's also another
thing
is when you got it what does the public
math thing mean like you're just not
willing to do it in front of people
yeah okay what's 1000
[Laughter]
is that like a general rule though like
if someone asks you yeah i don't do
public what's four times two you just
say i don't know
it starts to scale uh someone's like
spell cat and then next thing you know
they're like smell super cow fish and
you're just like
you're like i didn't want to get down
this road i should have even said who
asked you to spell
cat and you you say and then it goes to
super california
by the way john john i love you but uh
that's spelling this is math those are
two different
uh same act guys guys same thing all
right that's fine what is 105 000 times
a million wait so let's be clear i was
right
105 billion 105 billion yeah so we had
105 billion dollar
is that right yes are we positive okay
right no i don't know
oh see look joe's doing pogba he's
saying he's into detroit no it's 105
billion
105 billion dollars on his balance sheet
do we think he'd be a trillion dollar
business
105 right now he's got a four billion
dollar balance sheet he's got six
billion uh market cap give or take
but sentiment is down but the the
multiple would have to expand by
10. you don't think that what could
happen it'd actually be more like eight
but
who's counting yeah and then he's gonna
get in the whole concept of telling
everyone he changed the world
and his business is worth 10 times yeah
sure maybe
i mean it's an equity market anything
could happen yeah i mean
they literally have companies that are
pre-product pre-revenue trading at 50.
that's right
anything can happen yeah all you got to
do is tell people 2027 wait till we tell
you about our earnings that we're gonna
tell a good story all right so michael
saylor may have a trillion dollar
business on his hands we'll see uh if
bitcoin hits a million dollars
there's a possibility his business calls
basis seems to be around 26k too which
is uh
the cost for uh bitcoin yeah why tesla
sits around like 34th house wait how do
you
is are we sure that's the right number
26 000. yeah give her give or take a
thousand okay where are we getting that
data from
literally using how much he owns and how
much he paid for it
oh yeah yeah okay because he hasn't he
probably hadn't sold any
my uh michael sailor's not testing
liquidity the market
i do not think that he is testing any
liquidity um he also said that it was
digital real estate which i thought was
a very interesting
uh uh perspective because it is digital
real estate to some degree right there's
21 million
uh plots of land if you will on the
bitcoin network
and uh if you own one you're you're a
digital real estate owner i also said
you could take it to the grave
you know bury me with my life probably
not wrong
but you know
you